robbed one of the ideas of the movie
wishes our children I love that idea
it must have been a wish of yours a
dream of yours to adapt Sondheim to
adapt this Sondheim did also come with
some sleepless nights you know I've
always wanted to bring a Sondheim
musical to film it's a sort of something
you you know if you come from the
theater like I do it's it's it's this
amazing composer lyricist who you know
and and this piece that James wrote with
Steve is is iconic and beloved I mean I
loved at the moment I saw it in 1987 at
the Martin Beck theater and it was you
know and I've loved it ever since
Meryl you said that we were talking just
now that in preparation for it you kind
of had to learn the songs technically
without the emotion tatra so you could
learn it without breaking down as I have
several times while watching this movie
during the during the songs is that
correct you kind of had to learn it I
figured that out later you know I
thought well I'll just I'll just
practice the songs but you know I'm not
I'm an actor who tries to sing you know
and so feeling through the the music was
tricky because I would get moved and
then my voice would stop and choke and
so I had to kind of shut down and you
know musically bring my voice to where
it could physically deliver the song and
then and then I could play then I could
play with it but I really I really
worked hard I practiced 25 years since
the over 25 years since this felt this
play first this musical first debuted
did you see it adjust to the times has
it has it come to 2014 kind of the same
way you saw it in 1987-88 has it adapted
itself in certain ways well I think it
has and it's also adapted itself because
other people get to do it and that's a
great thing when you're a writer you
know it's fun I I do have the luxury of
being able direct the first production
of the things I do but then I'm more
than happy
and often see people do much better I
would say a better job but a more
enlightening job you know where you see
things in your work that you didn't
realize was there because somebody's
coming to it fresh so but you know I was
a different person
you know 28 years ago than I am now so
it is kind of like your kid and and you
grow with it and and you know I related
to the Baker when I wrote it and now I
relate to the baker's father there's
something really modern about Cinderella
and you know I think that speaks to how
timeless the fairy tales are and how
timeless this piece is and and just what
Rob wanted to do with it to make sure
that it felt alive and contemporary and
I think that yes her dilemma is a very
modern one which is this is a situation
that from the outside looks like it
should make me happy and everybody says
it should make me happy and I know it
should make me happy but my gut is
telling me that this is not right and
instead of listening to that I'm going
to you know just look at every possible
angle and just deconstruct everything
instead of trusting myself and trusting
my instincts and I'm you know going to
just throw the ball back in his court
and just see what happens
and you know she's just a very neurotic
princess which is which is great and I
and I felt I totally had permission from
Rob to do that and and permission from
Steve Sondheim that was his note to me
in the workshop like his one note was
you know she talks to birds you know
with with sunny Chicago and nine which
were the other musicals you know this
this was a you know this was not the
sort of there was not the sort of
theatricality I think attached to this
one we weren't working in that sort of
format of the sort of proscenium and and
the performance is taking place on a
stage or within the characters
imagination so for us I think the
challenge was to you know the lyrics of
the songs is the dialogue of the
movie and so we had to sort of find that
way find that language where the those
emotional moments when our characters
sing you know we're at a point where we
this song is as is as effective more
effective than saying those lines you
know so that was really sort of
something I think you know we wanted to
achieve and that was so different from
the other musical experiences you know
just finding that language and then of
course it was just trying to put this
world together you know a world that is
as a backdrop of fairy tale characters
but needed to be so grounded in a world
you know because I think we would have
done an injustice if the world of these
characters didn't feel grounded that if
it felt fantasy it felt to - fairy tale
I think you you sort of give up a lot of
the emotional complexity that these
characters are sort of experienced one
of the things we talked about at length
with everybody I mean I think
collaboration is very important with the
costume designer with Dennis Gassner our
production designer you know the sense
of reality because you're asked to care
about these characters you know these
aren't just sort of I know
two-dimensional fairytale characters you
have to believe right from the beginning
that that they have these dilemmas and
they want something and and they have
wishes and and and you have to care for
them throughout because you're asked to
by the end of this piece to really be
there and understand what they've been
through and not as sort of fairy tale
characters but as people it becomes more
real the piece you know in a way you've
got to look past the fairy tale you've
got to look past little red or Jack and
the Beanstalk and see the person you
know see the human being I suppose you
know editing you you mainly deal with
getting your story straight getting the
best performances for that story and
then really getting everybody out of the
theatre as quickly as you can in the
case of this James and Steven I mean the
story is so solid and
was such a great foundation with it
which really didn't have a lot of
problems to it's it's it's tested it
works so well
the performance is I mean obviously with
Anna Maryland Emily and James and are
the whole cast the performances was I
mean it's an embarrassment of riches so
it really comes down to about the pace
of all that and obviously its music and
kind of what Dion was saying your songs
are your scenes but the trick is is
you're not making a music video and
you're not relying on spectacle the
whole production is is so beautiful all
of that spectacle was going to come out
anyway it was going to be inherent but
James and Steven also don't write simply
you know if you if you think of a you
know when you're back to and when you've
had an or makes the or mean more than
its mean before or the fact that Anna's
you know he spread pitch on the stairs
and you're like that tar would be so
easy it's just an elegant word so the
key was really pacing and making sure
that in the what Rob had designed that
we were staying close with our actors
and really letting allowing you to
listen to what they were saying because
those words come a thousand miles an
hour Merrill I'm wondering there must be
inspirations for all of your
performances they come from lots of
different areas I'm wondering if there's
any inspirations for this one you can
share with us for myself ice all mostly
pre transformation which feels a little
bit like miss Habersham to me she
there's almost a very sad aspect of that
she's been waiting she's you know she's
sad and when waiting is there anything
like that that you can share that's very
funny because in 1975 I played Miss
Havisham and the Yale School of Drama in
a play that Christa rang in Alberta
Arado wrote and she was it was he it
wasn't really her but it was I based it
on her and I did my own makeup and I was
you know I thought I was hideous in 1975
but I was really [ __ ] great looking
and
I made myself into that now I mean I did
and and I look at that and so yes that's
definitely the inspiration for for that
was how I was fooling around with all
those things then how to play a bit a
witch I don't know it comes naturally in
the but the one thing that we've all
known about the witch which tells the
truth what does she say she's I'm not
good I'm not I'm not great I'm just I'm
telling you the truth I'm
straightforward right that must have
given you sort of something to to start
off with about that that is the way I am
so that was easy to you know I feel that
sort of thing about at home you know
often I feel I'm right and it's a curse
sort of like the curse of ugliness you
know so yeah a lot of lot of women feel
this one want that curse reversed though
I feel like I've grown with this piece
or that's grown with inside of me or I
mean I saw it for the first time the
Bernadette VHS tape and I felt really
grateful even at the time that I mean I
was think I was ten years old or
something and I and I such a rich piece
and it was so challenging
well now I've done it but okay but I
knew that you know it meant something
different to me at sixteen it will you
know it will it means something
different to me now it means something
different to me in a decade and and I
mean it absolutely is it's a piece about
parents and children and I and actually
my parents are you know I think about
the example that my parents set for me
in that scene with Chris because my
parents divorced when I was fifteen but
you know they all came to the premiere
and we all just had Thanksgiving
together and you know two
to set an example of civility within
that environment was you know something
I'll never be able to repay them for it
you know it probably wasn't easy for
them but you know I hope that that scene
is a reflection of what I got to
experience growing up